putting everybody I'm an Barker I'm
co-director of complex adaptive systems
at Arizona State University and director
of the National biomarker development
alliance and i'm a professor here at ASU
it's a great year to be talking about
biomarkers and I'll come back to that in
a second but the title this talk is
biomarkers an auspicious beginning and a
portentous future and I'll say more than
that as I go through the talk three
points to think about before we start
one is there's an opportunity on your
screen for questions and answers and so
if you have questions just write them
down and we'll attempt to answer them if
we don't get them all answered or if you
have questions after the talk here
welcome to submit those the second thing
this talk is being sponsored by roche
and we appreciate their participation
and less this talk is also eligible for
CME credit and if there any questions
about that you can you can contact your
institution so let's get started we're
going to talk about several things today
relative to biomarkers it's a space
where a lot of things are happening and
a lot of things are going to happen so
I'm going to talk today about a few
things that I like to bring to your
attention and one or two things that I
think will be critical for our
communities to start thinking about what
is we're going to start with some
definitions first of all I don't know
that anybody actually has a great
definition for biomarker and if you ask
10 people you probably will get 10
different responses but just for the
purposes of this talk we're going to
define biomarkers in a fairly classic
way I also want to talk a little bit
about the beginning of the biomarker
Science Space and and how does kind of
shape what we're doing today and and how
it's it's tended to shape maybe what
we'll do in the future but we have
opportunities to change that the other
thing I want to talk about is the state
of the science of biomarkers and it is a
science as a matter of fact is for the
largest experimental largest spaces and
the in the literature
field today and we'll come back to that
is presenting us some really tough
challenges and we're going to have to
deal with those challenges as a
community if you look to the future we
face them with some really really
interesting and sometimes daunting
problems that it has to do with the
complexity of cancer and the difficulty
we have with capturing that relative to
what a biomarker is and what a biomarker
might be in the future and in
recognition of that I'm going to bring
to your attention some concepts that FDA
is embraced some new regulatory paths or
some updated regulatory pass that needs
some real interests from our communities
in terms of the help that we need to
give the FDA to build the evidentiary
standards for biomarkers and then last
I'll tell you about a consortium that we
built in the last couple of years the
National biomarker development alliance
it's a trans sector model that
everyone's welcome to join but this is
probably the model this is probably the
way we'll build these evidentiary
standards in the future for biomarkers
and so with that let's get started so
what are we having why are we having all
these meetings and talking about cancer
and any given week you can go to I don't
know name you can pick a number of
biomarker meetings it's because of those
it's because of the burden of this
disease and I always start with a slide
like this because I spent a long time at
the National Cancer Institute and I
always started out by saying this is a
daunting problem it's one that actually
consumes a lot of our resources but it
also consumes a lot of our lives and it
takes a lot of people's lives and if you
think about these statistics and you can
read them they're twenty-five percent of
our population will succumb to this
disease and as our population is aging
we're talking more and more about this
now seventy-seven percent of cancers
diagnosed in individuals over the age of
55 which means that cancer in our
country is going to go up anywhere
between thirty and forty percent and as
little as 15 to 20 years that we're
already on that curve
um and if you look at the cost of cancer
it's it's certainly in the hundreds of
billions of dollars at NCI we estimated
it to be somewhere over 200 billion
that's just the direct cost of this
disease not the cost not the cost of
lives lost and productivity loss from
losing those individuals and it is not
just the u.s. problem if you if you
think about the problem globally it's
becoming one of the major issues of this
century and the World Health
Organization just I think two years ago
came out with these projections that by
2020 there will be 10.3 million deaths
and 16 million new cases of cancer
diagnosed every year globally and so
that's a seventy percent increase over
the next 20 years those projections were
in 2014 when I was at the NCI we had
lots of conversations with lots of
countries trying to prepare for this
countries like China for example where
the population is absolutely enormous
350 million smokers in China again we
have no biomarkers to predict which of
those individuals will get cancer so on
a global basis the economic impact and
the human impact is going to be
staggering so one of the tools that can
actually help us to impact this is is
going to be biomarkers so if you look at
the biggest problem we have in cancer
today and we are making some progress
but not nearly enough it's metastatic
disease so if you look at the concept of
a primary tumor where there is no
metastatic disease versus one where you
have metastatic disease or you develop
metastatic disease with most of these
cancers we don't do very well we have
never done very well and this is another
area where biomarkers are going to have
to come into play and help us to begin
to predict these individuals that are on
either lavanda metastatic disease or the
predicts
essentially when recurrence is going to
occur after primary treatment at cetera
so if you tell the two really daunting
problems that I think we're facing is
one that just a global incidence of this
disease and two is the complexity and
nature of this disease most especially
metastatic disease so that's really
brought us to the cusp of what we're all
talking about today and this has been
preceded by a molecular bio biology
revolution and a lot of advances in
molecular sciences but essentially our
vision now for 21st century medicine is
precision medicine and you see it every
day every day now people are getting
their genes sequence their genome
sequence there this is going to
physicians they're actually starting to
really use this as a tool to treat
patients yeah the obvious problem is the
number of limitations we have on the
number of drugs that match those
signatures are those biomarkers but the
healthcare realities are coming back to
our our previous thinking on the global
nature of this disease and the economic
impact this is one of the major issues
with healthcare today in terms of cost
and spending in 2013 was three trillion
it's going to continue to rise of a four
percent of more per year to become
twenty percent of our economy our dream
for the future is not essentially to
treat established disease not to use
cytotoxic therapies not to have people
diagnosed extraordinarily late but to
have an entirely new approach where
biomarkers can drive us city tech
disease early and actually treat it in a
targeted way knowing what the molecular
profile is and that connects patient
care back to the laboratory in a
continuous cycle and that is all
dependent precision medicine is
dependent on the availability of robust
very very effective biomarkers and that
in fact makes biomarkers probably the
highest value in precision medicine or
any kind of medicine today so the
highest value proposition is probably
me biomarkers so what are we talking
about this like all things we have to
find this whole concept of biomarkers
quite officially and so you've read this
definition probably numerous times but
it a biomarker is a characteristic thus
objectively measured that's very
important and it's evaluated usually a
change in the patient that you can
measure is an indication of a normal
process or one that represents pathology
of some kind or something you can
measure after you enter being with with
the drug say or a biologic and the small
print is very important it should be
clinically relevant fit for purpose
which means it should be used and useful
for exactly what you say or to do with
it should be measurable and reproducible
big issue with biomarkers and directly
reflect the state even the normal or the
altered state that's a lot of things to
think about when you start defining
these things so one of the weather
really important uses for biomarkers is
as surrogate endpoints now if you think
about this this is kind of the holy
grail biomarkers and essentially this
was defined quite a long time ago by
Robert temple at the FDA and it hasn't
changed essentially in terms of what a
surrogate endpoint can be it's a
laboratory measurement or physical sign
that's used in therapeutic trials as a
substitute for clinically meaningful
endpoint and it has to be a direct
measure of how a patient feels functions
or survives and that's expected to
predict the effect of the therapy now
that if you put all that together it
means that biomarkers as surrogate
endpoints are pretty rare and in
oncology they're almost non-existent so
the idea that we can develop biomarkers
that can substitute for clinical
endpoints is a terrific idea and it's
actually the basis for accelerated
approval the drug at the FDA but to this
point in time we have very few of these
for some reasons that were
talk about as we go through the rest of
these slides some other terms that I
like people to remember when you're
talking about biomarkers you have to
build assays for them obviously you have
to know what sensitivity is you have to
be able to correctly identify
essentially the biomarker be looking for
the specificity the precision is the
closest between the independent results
obtained under these defined conditions
over and over again fit-for-purpose
essentially is used by the FDA it
defines the context of use for the
biomarker that's very important term and
then we see we're operating curves
anybody works in this field essentially
uses these to determine the accuracy of
chess so these are if these are not
terms that are familiar to you now and
you want to be in the biomarker space
these are terms that will become
familiar so biomarkers are as I said
probably the highest value that we have
in the whole field to precision medicine
today that's not to say that you can't
be kind of blockbuster drug you can
bring in a lot of revenue but if you
actually think about what you could do
if we could really really build the
right biomarkers in terms of the value
of biomarkers in the value proposition
would be incredible be incredible
because you could drive therapy
development detect disease very early
help you choose treatments assess
whether or not your treatments working
give you a good prognostic indicator for
so you can tell your patient what to
expect essentially we hope someday to
prevent with biomarkers understand what
kind changes might be important in terms
of disease onset then treatment disease
monitoring would essentially occur
treatment druzy of the mind I'm sorry by
screens that we have disconnected I hope
that's not true treatment disease
monitoring circuit endpoints essentially
as I said and an accelerated approval
for a drugged and essentially where you
have that kind of employee
so if you're if you're a patient you
might ask some of these kinds of
questions for example you know what type
of cancer do I have or is this the right
drug for me or what's this what's the
optimal dose of this drug from the air
will the cancer returned etc so it's
this is also an area where patients will
become more and more involved because as
they know what which questions to ask
biomarkers will become much more patient
centric so let's now talk a little bit
about this auspicious beginning for
biomarkers and biomarkers go might go
back almost as far as one can imagine
because a biomarker can be nearly
anything in terms of the kinds of things
that you can measure you could be an
image so imaging biomarkers are very
powerful it can be some of the early
kinds of biomarkers that I'm going to
show you a little bit about now it can
be these very sophisticated
sophisticated biomarkers that can be
algorithms that integrate big data sets
everything's on the table when it comes
to biomarkers if it's if it meant if it
meets that criteria a measuring best
sort of change and doing it reproducibly
and measurably it can be a biomarker so
some early wins so we had never a lot of
early wins in the biomarker space and
this now we're talking about very early
we're talking about late last century
probably as early as the early 1990s you
started getting biomarkers approach
cardiovascular disease lend away and
everybody's wanted to look like
cardiovascular disease ever sets in so
we keep talking about these great
biomarkers like blood pressure and that
that's one that still is used remarkably
well for all kinds of drug development
HIV this was actually prompted by crisis
but cd4 counts are used every day as
essentially in drug development and also
in patient care and then in diabetes
hemoglobin a1c you'll see it coming up
all the time with FDA
in terms of how drugs are assessed them
and and use so I want to tell you a
little bit about this cardiovascular
story because it's a really complicated
story and it's one that we can learn
from so I'm going to tell you the good
news and the bad news here so surrogate
endpoints and this is the disease that
has the most certain points when you
think about it this is a really good
case for successful approaches and I
want to flip down a slide a little bit
because this all started with the
Framingham study which is a huge
cardiovascular study sponsored by the
NIH started as early as 1940 1948 at
NHLBI and essentially was to sort of
find out what causes heart attacks and
stroke it had more than 5,000 patients I
think I think by the time they actually
were done it was published in 1961 and
they actually isolated and just and
actually had sound data for these risk
factors like you know like
cardiovascular disease and cholesterol
levels and blood pressure etc and and
even in some of the arrhythmias you know
like we were measuring by ECG ECG then
what those arrhythmias were and what
they might need so these things became
the targets very quickly for drug
intervention and in combination with all
kinds of other technologies imaging it's
produced really profound results the
decrease in mortality from
cardiovascular disease has been stunning
and as a matter of fact all cause
mortality the biggest impact probably
has a Benton from this whole issue
starting all the way back in the early
part of the last century that we
actually did a study that really changed
this disease and changed all cause
mortality so this really prompted an
enormous number of clinical research
studies and if you if you think about
sorry you think about the fact that all
these all these biomarkers have been
approved and
in place for many many decades now the
clinical trials which were really quite
early started nearly 2000s were really
quite seminal in setting sort of the
course for how biomarkers would be
developed and improved so if you if you
look then and how many of these things
were so beautifully done and we're
impacting very positively there was a
there was an event in this whole process
that changed just about everything in
the way we developed biomarkers and the
way we judge them and how careful we
have to be especially around surrogate
endpoints and this saga essentially is
best captured in something called a cast
trial and essentially a casserole was
based on the concept that ventricular
premature beats was a excellent
surrogate endpoint for survival after an
mi so and this was at this time sudden
death after an mi was at least the
physicians felt as though was very
tightly correlated to these premature
event ticket ventricular beats things
are not always as they seem so the cast
trial began in nineteen eighty and there
were just a slew of a rhythmic savella
purring that period and because it was a
very popular sort of class of drugs
because it was going to essentially make
a lot of revenue for the companies that
were making them so in 1980 it's very
interesting it was so accepted by the
community that this particular biomarker
was in fact a surrogate endpoint that
people didn't really want to do this
trial they thought it would be unethical
to do this trial but anyway science
persevered and they did the trial
starting in nineteen eighty and they
affected they looked at the effect of
these three drugs on in post-mi and a
lot of patience and essentially their
premise was that that this endpoint
would actually be predicted
for survival in these patients post-mi
so they were able to suppress the VP B's
nicely probably by half I think but they
double mortality so essentially these a
rhythmic drugs increased mortality
significantly they were essentially
wrong the whole premise was wrong it
costs a lot of lives so what people
finally internalize is that surrogate
endpoints have to think about or have to
consider the fact that you are going to
have to integrate a lot of issues if
you're going to come to a clinical
endpoint so this was the first real
discussion of off target effects and
other factors that come into certain
points and it was consciousness-raising
at every level and essentially made our
communities understand once and for all
that surrogate endpoints are
extraordinarily difficult to achieve and
biomarkers achieving that status is a
very very high bar if you look at what
happened in cancer and this was this
started this particular drug Gleevec
which is in fact the drug that started
the whole revolution and cancer around
again probably the mid-2000s people
began to work on this brian druker
organelle Health Science University is
responsible for the development of this
biomarker and essentially this one was
discovered in a way that took about 50
years it was observed 50 years ago that
the Philadelphia chromosome has you know
that all of these patients had a similar
sort of genetic defect but it took
another 50 years to figure out where it
was on the chromosome how it behaved etc
and to get it modeled but this is the
this is sort of the way that I think the
field have gone since we really fell in
love with the idea that if you know a
molecular change in a tumor then
you can probably build a drug to it now
that doesn't really consider in some
cases today that this particular
molecular change has to be totally
related or certainly in principle has to
be totally related to the disease and
the causation of the disease this is
true for chronic myelogenous leukemia
and and this particular this particular
abnormality it was almost a miracle drug
and it was approved in 2002 probably one
of the shortest review cycles in the
history of the FDA so you have two
stories played out here really three
when you have two very successful early
days of their cardiovascular world where
you had things like blood pressure and
cholesterol and and some of these other
biomarkers that are still used today and
it's really affected really really
effective mortality you hit men you have
you have cast trial which has certain
got everybody's attention in terms of
what a biomarker should be and what a
surrogate endpoint but by working is
going to be a certain point has to
really really be and and then along
along comes all of his progress we have
in cancer and we turn our attention to
molecular biomarkers and this along with
her too and Herceptin are one of the two
kinds of biomarkers that have changed
the field forever so we started out with
a very audacious dishes beginning and we
now we have a very pretentious future
because of our because of our molecular
sciences and the kinds of projects that
we've done things like the Cancer Genome
Atlas etc is giving us a lot and
molecular data so let's let's look at
the biomarker field and interesting
biomarker for the biomarker field like
most of cancer research is driven by
technology and I don't mean that in a
way that says it's not also driven by
intellect and team science and think
innovation and all the other things that
we think about but will we use every day
in these laboratories to
big biomarkers are really technologies
and those technologies keep evolving and
it started out a long time ago with very
simple kinds of approaches to sequencing
it's called Sanger sequencing still use
it today we now know how to look at the
transcriptome very carefully to RNA seek
our mass spec is still we still have
issues with some of the standards but
it's becoming a very powerful technology
epigenomics has found its way into most
people's hands now and we're beginning
now to think down here in terms of
biomarkers and the way that cells
function communicate etc is going to be
also closely tied to the spatial in
micro environmental effects so there is
coming out of roll with this a
multi-dimensional data explosion that's
amazing and if you look at this this is
essentially what's also driving
biomarker science huge amounts of data
and that data is coming in all kinds of
forms the variety is amazing when you
consider the clinical data that has to
go with all molecular data the rate is
unbelievably almost exponential now in
terms of acceleration and the data types
are pretty much almost unbelievable in
terms of numbers of types of data that
we're getting today so that is producing
huge opportunity in our field but it's
also producing huge challenges this you
talk about a pretentious future this
whole issue of big data and how we're
going to analyze it how we're going to
turn this into biomarkers for
understanding the natural history of
disease or actually coming up with
biomarkers that we can approve
incrementally up toward a toward the
coming say a surrogate endpoint is
probably one of the greatest one of the
greatest opportunities we've ever had in
biomedicine so what's driving all this I
had something to do with some of this
dr. Collins and I when I was at the NIH
and he I least I
something called the Cancer Genome Atlas
which has produced petabytes of data on
many many tumors but these these
technologies are now essentially driving
almost unimaginable amounts of data
being actually being developed and
globally in 2014 I think it actually
exceeded 28 pair of I petabytes of data
and nobody quite knows what this is
going to look like in the future but
there are countries actually proposing
to sequence huge segments of their
population and a thousand petabytes a
year probably is not an unreasonable way
of thinking if in fact this is going to
be the foundational element of precision
medicine so how do you understand all
this how do you bring any kind of
understanding for that much data so
here's an example from the Cancer Genome
Atlas is the first paper we published
out of the Atlas and it was interesting
because it allowed us to sort of think
this through how do you organize data so
we organized this data around known
pathways and pathways that were very
important especially in the glioblastoma
process this is that this is a slightest
from the glioblastoma paper but
essentially what we found the further we
looked is yes we could subtype these
different diseases with in GBM related
to their molecular changes but if you
looked at it on a patient by patient
basis they were more like snowflakes
essentially I like that term because
it's there was a there was an organizing
construct that we could look at but
within the organizing construct every
single one was different and there is a
real message there that we have to
understand in terms of how we use
genomic data in the future because every
patient is going to have a signature
it's going to be part of a larger
signature but every patient is going to
have their own unique signature so I
want to say a couple of words here I
gave a talk on this a couple of years
ago maybe here I can't recall but I
a lot about this because the National
biomarker development lights is trying
to attack this problem and a lot of the
other problems in biomarker science but
I'm going to stop here and talk a little
bit about this because this whole data
explosion which has been going on it's
been going on for almost 30 years now
maybe longer certainly since we we
finished the completion that we
completely human genome but it's
produced an embarrassment we thought
rich's but in fact we've got literally
hundreds of thousands of biomarkers
published a literature literally if you
go look you will be stunned and this has
become a real focus for a lot of the
public and increasingly for the Congress
and other people who think about the
value of research and even today there's
an article in Christian monitor that
christian science monitor today on a
reproducibility of science and it's been
covered in science several times it's
been covered in New Yorker it's been
covering the Economist it spinning it
uncovered and you know in nature it's
been covered in every almost everywhere
in every public sort of periodical it's
the reproducibility of these data is is
important because as I've just shown you
unless you're biomarkers are robust
sound it's going and other people can
reproduce them it's going to lead to
this kind of problem so this is a
problem the communities have to address
to make bias to make biomarker science
the science that we need for the future
that pretentious future will only be
realized if we saw this biomarker
reproducibility problem and just to show
you this is a my colleague George post
published this paper I always like to
show it because this was all the way
back in 2011 but 150,000 claimed
biomarkers that year and essentially
we've approved about one protein
biomarker per year since the early 1990s
so it's a it's a pretty dismal it's a
pretty dismal picture but there's great
opportunity here i don't i'm not very
pessimistic about it i think all these
problems can be solved
so what we're going to do now is we're
to talk about that a little bit so how
do we you know how do we take the sort
of the auditions audacious beginning of
the biomarker revolution we learned a
lot from cardiovascular disease we
learned a great deal from the way the
BCR Abel for example alteration was
developed and that drug was developed
same thing with her too and we've got a
lot of those not a lot we've had some of
those examples since then but now we're
looking at a future and it's very
pretentious with promise but how are we
going to do how we going to actually
navigate the future to get there and
what has to be done what do we have to
think about what do you have to think
about in your laboratory so if I look to
the future I think the one issue that's
going to really be important that we
understand and we be able to start
thinking about how you capture real
complexity complexity of cancer in
something that we call a biomarker and
that means that a lot of us have to
change so this data tsunami that we're
seeing we've got to learn how to use
that in our favor essentially and
improve the review sister we produce
data and and also to open new doors for
how you develop not just how you
discover my mother's but how you develop
them so I think we should embrace this
period because I think it was an author
wrote recently in science up so I've
forgotten his name but he mentioned that
this whole crisis and reproducibility is
really a huge opportunity for our field
it's happened in other fields and going
from you know from sort of a prototype
to manufacture anymore all the data that
goes into a prototype before you get
demands other fields have had to go
through this and we're going to have to
go through it now and we can so this is
slice I made a long time ago and I still
like it but essentially cancer is a
complex evolving system it's not just a
system that
we you know you put in place and that
never changes its evolving and all the
environmental effects that you have
internally and externally can impact
this system so if you think about this
but you've got to be able to capture is
once you get out here the malignant
state and you've got to be able to
capture that state and the same thing is
true with the earlier state it's it's a
challenge but I think it's going to be
doable so if you think about it as a the
complex adaptive system a lot of the
hallmarks of cancer kind of coming to
focus then because you can see the
interactions as to why as to why for
example angiogenesis is an important
aspect of cancer or its its ability to
replicate uncontrollably a gun control
is one of the hallmarks but essentially
the numbers of elements which are multi
scalar the robustness of the system a
lot of backup systems in cancer it's
very adaptable and very vulnerable and
that in fact leads to what we think of
as the metastatic phenotype and that
produces all kinds of problems for us in
terms of resistance so we have to
understand this disease much better as a
complex system so how can you do that I
don't have the answer to this I mean I
have a lot of ideas but one thing that
I'm intrigued with is exosomes exosomes
are really interesting in the sense that
they capture a lot of complexity and
they can also capture some aspects of
the micro environment as well as some of
the evolutionary kinds of aspects that
we're looking for so I think this is one
of those areas that will have some real
promise I think also another area that I
like a lot is this whole issue of
algorithms and how you develop
algorithms to really interrogate a data
set that will tell you something about
the question you're asking clinically
and I see a future where we will have
algorithm serving as SS biomarkers and
there are others i think i think sorry
waiting tumor cells has promised we
haven't actually
been able to do a lot with that promise
yet but there are there are aspects I
think we should start thinking about
better much more complicated than those
single genomic changes or even a few
genomic changes we're really early in
this revolution and we need to all
understand that it's got a long way to
go so I want to talk in that I wanted to
come back to surrogate endpoints because
I think that if we're going to
eventually replace many of these very
long long clinical in fights which
require sometimes years to actually get
to survival or another clinical endpoint
and I think we do coming back to this
complexity question how do we actually
start to think about surrogate endpoints
and these are there some long-standing
issues here and I wanted to bring them
to your attention today so you can begin
to think about them as you start to
think about your own career in the
biomarker space so coming back to what
we said this line that I've underlined
here it is in fact sort of the key issue
here it's it's how a patient feels
functions and survives is is a very
interesting as a very interesting way to
look at this and there are lots of
examples where people have submitted
very very sophisticated biomarkers for
certain diseases and if you think about
it something very practical turns out to
be a much better liar by Walker because
it's a measure of how the patient is
functioning so biomarkers actually are
classically defined mathematically and
this particular ross Prentice who when
he wrote this was at the hutch out in
Seattle but essentially this is the
criteria for a surrogate endpoint to be
a surrogate endpoint so if you think
about this it's a true endpoint that's
the clinical endpoint the surrogate
endpoint is what you hope that you'll
get approved and then as he is the
variable for treatment and the effects
here and the interactions here are
really quite profound and
extraordinarily difficult difficult
these criteria have never been met
for a surrogate endpoint so I'll just
leave that if that's the ideal there
have been surrogate endpoints approved
but not that met this criteria so here
are some surrogate endpoints that we all
and cancer know a lot about pathologic
complete response essentially we got
that approved a couple years ago for
neoadjuvant breast cancer time to
progression is in cancers are valuable
as a valuable cert at endpoint these are
able i mentioned before and these are a
couple of a couple of the ones that we
know from other fields but essentially
glaucoma and and cardiovascular disease
represent two very strong surrogate
endpoints so there are some huge
challenges here so what is it about you
know biomarkers it makes all this so
difficult it's the complexity coming
back to the complexity of the disease so
it is unlikely the single biomarker even
maybe a few genes are going to tell you
all that much about the clinical outcome
it's a multi-factorial multi systems
oregon-based and the organs are
connected and very end variable in their
responses and the effects of drugs on
those audiences is can be very profound
so one clinical endpoint may not provide
the complete picture for the overall
clinical outcome because multiple
clinical endpoints can even court don't
necessarily even correlate with each
other so the clinical endpoints themself
can be an issue the drawing board a
biologic they do other things as we
showed we showed in the kestrel you may
in fact have all kinds of off target
effects and then circuits may not be
related outcome again as we saw in the
in the castro and it turns out that you
know that is an endpoint which is not a
clinical endpoint in the cast Raleigh
doesn't predict the clinical outcome so
another example is the white count or
fibra essentially those are those are
very good examples that are not related
to the to the clinical outcome
patient so I'm going to stop here and
give you some information that I want
you to take away from this talk and that
is most people are looking to biomarkers
to be surrogate endpoints essentially to
predict what's going to happen in a
patient exactly what's going to happen
in a patient that's a very high bar very
high bar there are lower bars that will
allow you to use biomarkers in an
extraordinarily high value way and I
want to tell you a little bit about that
because I think the surrogate endpoints
story has taken us away from some of the
real promise of biomarkers that can be
used in patients to do a lot of things
that need to be done so biomarker
qualification is essentially defining a
context of use for a biomarker and then
figuring out how you qualify that
biomarker so if you if you think about
the whole process of biomarker
qualification it's it's not exactly like
drug development but there is it's a
little bit analogous so essentially
you've got to decide first on the
context abuse you have to decide on you
statements how are you going to use it
within that context and then what are
the conditions for qualified use so you
have to be pretty concise and all of
this you have to think it through and
you have to have evidence so if you
think about the process and just let me
just take you quickly through the
process so biomarker qualification is
really helping us to develop a whole set
of tools to to do a lot of things to
develop drugs most especially but other
things as well so if you if you think
about it you could you safety and
effectiveness assigning patients to
clinical trials all the patient have
stable disease there are all kinds of
questions that you want to ask in a
clinical trial and you can do that so
here's the
ss FDA has started this process all the
way back in 2004 revise it this slide
that you're looking at here is from dr.
federico good said who started that
process at FDA but essentially what you
do is you you or your organization can
submit an application through a letter
of intent to the FDA and then
essentially you you're going to have to
say what you want to qualify and what
the context of use for that is that will
go into the FDA and get reviewed and
then you will you will present to the
FDA a package that contains your context
of use and all of the evidentiary
standards that you need to prove for the
prove that context reviews and once FDA
approves it they put it into the Federal
Register and essentially once i get the
comments back it can be used and what's
really interesting is that once it's
approved other people can use it it
doesn't have to be reapproved and it's
independent of the technology so it's a
very powerful approach to actually doing
the right things with biomarkers with
patients and i personally a big fan of
this process and it's gotten a lot of
attention this year because of the 21st
century cures bill which has been
rolling around Capitol Hill now like
those things but there's a very big
section in there on on how you actually
do this and so the one thing that I'll
come back to in a second is FDA is not
going to develop the evidentiary
standards for these various contexts of
use the communities have to do that it's
going to require consort to do that and
this is a place where our communities
can start to take leadership so if you
i'm going to give you an example okay
the best way to do this is just to show
you how you might do this so again
giving credit to my colleague dr. good
said he believes and i think he's right
that if we do this right and do it well
we can start to develop the evidentiary
standards as communities
in an incremental way in other words you
can develop your context of use
incremental e-everything can't be a
surrogate endpoint so maybe you start
with a lower level of context if you
send you work your way up in terms of
standards and here's an example for
circulating tumor cells know this is all
kind of made up but let's just say that
you wanted select patients for clinical
trials and essentially the action in
terms of what you have to do for CTCs
then there is an approved device when
you would have to do essentially it's
not very much if anything to essentially
say that you could use this you could
use this technology or use this
biomarker but essentially you wanted him
lay out the risks on the benefits and
then you want to define the evidentiary
standards that are needed so here let's
say you need to establish you establish
the correlation of ctcs in a prior
experiment and number I can't be back
number of prior to initiation of therapy
and survival on prognosis so you've
already done that study so this might be
an approvable context of use this first
line right there will be approval if you
look down at the bottom at the bottom
avoiding feudal treatments for example
that would be a biomarker the context of
use would be treatment resistance so all
of these things can be sorted if you
know what context of use you understand
what the risk is to the patient but what
the benefit is to the patient and you
can define the evidentiary standards you
can present that to the FDA that's a
very powerful way to go to the FDA to
get your bio marker in your hands to use
in the clinic in a way that will benefit
patients and it doesn't all and by the
way these are not Diagnostics nor are
they companion diagnostics so you have
to understand that these will these are
tools that can be used in clinical
development and certainly in drug
development and I think they're I think
they're probably the one of the biggest
maybe the most promising area
in in biomedicine today to show you a
little bit about maybe how you could
approach this if you're interested in
sort of how you fix these problems I
want to give you just a little history
of something in I did over the last two
and a half three years I am
extraordinarily frustrated with the
state of the biomarker science
everywhere and did a lot about that
tried to do a lot about that when I was
at the NCI we and we spent a lot of time
fund a lot of projects especially
national initiative and proteomics we
did the same thing certainly in genomics
we tried to bring will rigor to the way
we we identify genomic changes through
the Cancer Genome Atlas etc but the
truth is on biomarkers that's the
largest by the largest segment of the
data that's a good that is so being you
know blasted out there as being not
reproducible a lot of its biomarker data
and we aren't improving biomarkers very
easily because we don't we haven't done
the work we just haven't done the work
so if I look at what we have tried to
address essentially as one of the things
that Janet Woodcock said years ago when
she developed a critical path initiative
at the FDA is that we don't have any
common standards or best practices or
guidelines to drive end and biomarker
development and it's a process that
starts with discovery and ends when you
get it approved either as a surrogate
endpoint or as a development tool if you
want to if that's your ultimate goal but
we only have any real decision tools to
go through this process and it's not
FDA's job to develop these standards
it's our job and so we took that long at
the National Bar market developments and
we've been working on that for a couple
years almost three years with a couple
hundred experts and we've had a lot of
success but our overall goal is to is to
develop some systems that the
communities can use to bring solutions
to their work so that biomarker
discovery can move through development
and in two patients that are much more
rapid rate and we can actually achieve
precision medicine so coming back to
sorry that's wrong way this is some of
the work that we've done we hold these
think tanks and if you want to join us
sometime it would be it's really fun and
sometimes painful because we deal with
tough problems but we've tackled
everything from biomarker discovery to
the surrogate endpoint to some of the
issues with clinical trials and
development itself in other words you
know how do you actually go about
developing a biomarker and all of these
things are available for you to review
on our website but essentially
everything we did has taught us a few
things and there are things that you
should take away from this talk every
biomarker experiment has to begin with a
clinically important clinical question
if you don't start there you end up at
the end of whatever it is you're doing
potentially with an answer but an answer
that has no real relevance so you have
to have a robust experimental design
that means you have to talk to
statisticians and you have to be sure
that the statistics is going to support
the answer to your question so much of
our data is not statistically sound
biospecimens one of the things that I
have worked on just for a very long time
and the biospecimens here have to be
they really have to be robust in terms
of quality you have the right numbers
depending on your status issues the
technologies that you employ happy new
standards you have the new standards and
it's not that we don't have standards
for technologies as we have all kinds of
standards and then all the data that you
collect must be a very high quality and
you must have the province with the data
or the metadata to tell you where the
data camera and then finally this is a
weak area analytics and analysis that
are responsive to your experimental
design they must be appropriate and
robust and this is an error
where we need a lot of training because
in looking at say you know expression
looking at the transcriptome etc you've
got to be able to go in and use the
right kind of algorithms to find signal
and some of those data sets and and then
we produce ibly go to another data set
to see a random a set to see how valid
your signal is so we came up with this
little graphic and essentially this is
not in I mean this is not the way the
world works I mean some of these things
go on obviously in parallel but early
discovery is where our discovery per se
is where most things start to fail and
making a decision to translate something
from that red circle to that blue circle
involves a lot of money and it should be
an extraordinarily carefully bait
decision because once you start building
essays and you have to develop them that
you have to know if this essay is going
to be scalable it can answer your
question it's met all those other
criteria and then the purple the purple
circle there is qualification if you
qualify your bio marker and you can use
it in all kinds of ways to build the
best clinical trials to to actually find
out about the toxicity of your drugs to
dose drugs better etc and then somewhere
out here on the yellow and that yellow
circle you can you can actually turn
these things and asserted endpoints by
validating them in clinical trials and
standards are required at each and every
step of this and that's where we're
falling down and I think that's going to
happen it is happening now lots of
groups like ours are are really getting
on board in terms of developing these
kinds of standards so what so we ask
yourself a few questions we said you
know are there systemic problems here
that we can address and our answer was
yes there are some systemic bugs so
we've taken on one go check it on two
and i'll tell you about the second one
but this one is very very interesting in
talking to our chief medical officer at
the mvd a dr. Carol Ann Compton she said
you're never going to be able to do
precision medicine and the communities
because the pathology labs are not set
up to do it and they're overseen by the
College of American Pathologists and
it's just it doesn't fit in the hospital
flow and all the things you want to do
they have the quality that you need for
molecular essays is extraordinarily
difficult to implement so we found a
partnership with the College of American
Pathologists essentially what they did
was a tackle this problem very
interestingly they said worthy you know
what are the eighty percent of the
effects that cause failure of
biospecimens about twenty percent of
them actually so they came up with a
list of you know of variables that have
to be controlled essentially to get from
any Hospital anywhere that cap overseas
around the country what is what do they
have to do to produce a very high
quality biospecimen so those performance
metrics they're gonna vita are being
developed in kept and nvda are working
on process to to actually institute
those and that means that eventually any
patient can get a very high quality
molecular SI in any Hospital if camp is
actually overseeing the implementation
of these particular performance metrics
because if you know if eighty percent of
the problems come from twenty percent
that's that's all fixable so some of the
other things that were working on
essentially for this whole issue of how
do you come up with a good clinical
question we're trying to establish some
baseline biomarkers for certain diseases
and outcome biomarkers for some other
diseases or those some some of the same
diseases and and working at biomarkers
for the sum of the stochastic effects of
treatment to help us to begin to help
others to define what is a clinically
important question and then design-wise
this is tough because a lot of people
aren't really experts in design so we're
going to bring the process of trying to
put together a commons for biomarker
design we could put some of these mounts
up for people to understand
and as I said we we've set up this
approach with the College of American
Pathologists essence and we're
undertaking for with the FDA some case
studies for biomarker qualifications for
of them actually to to say that you're
here for diseases here's what we believe
the evidentiary standards would have to
be for these contexts of use here the
risk etc so these case studies will be
very important and if you have a case
study and you'd like the NVDA to work
with your case study then just contact
me so we're not a big organization we're
a few committed people who who actually
have a lot of committed colleagues so
we're a small organization that
leverages an enormous amount of
expertise and have a lot of a lot of
progress because of that and this is the
future I think this is the way the world
is going to be I think a few people can
leverage a lot of the intellect that's
out there to solve these problems so
maybe years ago I saw this I saw this
light Daniel us who work in one of the
one of the programs i had the NCI call
the physical sciences oncology centers
it quite an accomplished mathematician
so he said maybe this is what we should
be thinking about in terms of the way
we're going to treat patients in the
future but since patients are very
complex systems you have to start
thinking about this as you know as the
inputs and the outputs and then how
you're going to actually manage those
and biomarkers is a big piece of that
the molecular data is a big piece but
there are all these other biomarkers and
other outputs that you're going to have
to consider and especially what comes
from the patient you're hearing a lot
today about patient reported outcomes so
what's the patient's saying about the
gut and all of those things would feed
into a lot of information a very high
information content set of interventions
that would be used in the future to
actually treat patients as complex
systems which I think line workers will
be absolutely pivotal pivotal to achieve
but I can begin to see that portentous
future
begin to see that we can fix these
biomarker problems and and potentially
offer this kind of approach to patients
which would be which will probably be
comprehensive and it would do a great
deal more in terms of increasing
longevity and quality of life Lee
patients that we're doing now so to
summarize giving a lot of information
today you know what a biomarker is what
a surrogate endpoint is what we mean by
context abuse the approaches that you
can actually take through the FDA to get
your biomarker into some kind of
development process I favor that
qualification process it's an
incremental process it's one that
requires evidentiary standards but we
can as a community we can fix that and
it's up to you to organize your own if
you've got a context of use if you've
got a group of people want to work on
that you want to do a case study then I
would say that's the way to start
finally I those of you that know me but
I believe there is strongly coalition's
of the Willing or the way to change the
world and for this biomarker issue and
there are many issues I think this is I
think this is something that will depend
on the community engagement in
developing those evidentiary standards
and I know FDA is depending on it so I
thank you for your time today we don't
have much time left I'm sorry at along
at a LAN presentation but if you have
any questions you can type them now or
you can send them after this is over or
you can send them to me at my email
address is Anna a and n a dot barker VAR
keer at asu.edu and I would especially
love to hear from people who have great
ideas for biomarker qualification cases
because i think the FDA is that i have
to have a number of those submitted over
the next few years to really begin to
build these processes so we can get
these biomarkers into clinical trials
so with that I think I will let you know
that this presentation will be available
for order for about six months and your
questions will also you know get
answered if I see them so thank you all
for joining us today this is a great way
to get information out there that I want
out there in terms of what we can do
about this field and what you can do to
help us to make us feel less of a
problem and more of an opportunity at
which I think that's as I said earlier
this is probably the opportunity of the
ages so finally if you want to if you
would like to join us on NVDA here's our
contact information and you can go on
our site and see some of the things I've
talked about today so again thank you
very much for your time and I look
forward to hearing for you if you have
interest in talking about biomarker
qualification